The survey results are in, and guess what
- we're all a bunch of hateful idiots!
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - with some
eye-opening survey results that show just
how entrenched anti-Semitism is in places
all around the globe.
An organization called the Anti-Defamation
League commissioned a worldwide survey recently,
polling over 53,000 adults across 102 countries,
in order to gauge attitudes about Jewish people.
And if it wasn't obvious already - the results...
are not great.
According to the poll, 1 in 4 adults worldwide
are "deeply infected with anti-Semitic attitudes";
almost half have never heard of the Holocaust,
and a third of the people who have heard of
it - believe it's either a myth, or has been
extremely exaggerated.
The survey featured a set of 11 traditional
anti-Semitic statements - like "Jews are responsible
for most of the world's wars" or "Jews think
they're better than other people" - and then
had people answer whether they thought those
statements were "probably true" or "probably
false."
Of all the adults polled, a whopping 26% believed
at least 6 of the 11 stereotypes to be true
- which equates to almost 1.1 billion people
worldwide.
And of that 26%, nearly three quarters of
them admitted to never having met a Jewish
person.
Regions with the most anti-Semitic attitudes,
were the Middle East and North Africa - where
74% of adults agreed with the majority of
the anti-Semitic remarks.
The absolute highest levels - reaching 93%
- were found in Palestinian territories and
Iraq.
Yet only 8% of adults in those regions had
even heard of the Holocaust.
The most popular stereotype was that Jews
are more loyal to Israel than to the countries
in which they live.
It's not all bad, though - there do appear
to be regions of the world where anti-Semitism
is virtually nonexistent.
In Laos, for example - only 0.2% of the population
hates Jews.
And The Philippines, Sweden, and the Netherlands
- were also extremely tolerant.
In the United States, 9% of respondents were
considered anti-Semitic.
The survey also shows that the majority of
people have no clue how many Jews there actually
are in the world.
Currently, they make up .19% of the global
population - but three-quarters of the adults
polled assumed they comprised at least 1%
- and almost a tenth thought that Jews accounted
for more than 20% of the world's population.
Also interesting - is that people who overestimated
the Jewish population, were also more likely
to harbor anti-Semitic views.
If you wanna see a more complete breakdown
of the survey results, we have a link in the
description of this episode - and it's pretty
enlightening, so I recommend checking that
out.
As always if you have questions, comments,
anything NON-HATEFUL you wanna say about this
survey, then leave your thoughts in the comments
below.
Otherwise, thank you for watching!